The number of our citizens who lost their lives
reached 18,991, Yuksel reached 523.
Moreover, over 7 of
our citizens from the region were evacuated to other provinces, while
12,432 of our citizens
died. We know that, according to our belief, Adem, who lost his life in the earthquake,
destroyed all of these buildings. Family
All institutions, personnel,
equipment
and aid of our state
spread over an area of ​​1,000 kilometers.  We
have a job
to organize.
Most of the public officials themselves or
their families
are under destruction, some
of them are the
ruins caused by the earthquake, some of them are the
public denials in our state and all its cities.